Uh, is it live?
I can't tell.
Uh, oh, I think so.
Sorry.
I'm nervous.
Hello, everybody.
Hi.
Oh, gosh.
I'm nervous.
Oh, I don't, I'm not used to stuff like this.
Um, I wanted to, I wanted to keep this kind of short.
I just, um, uh, wanted to clear up some stuff.
Uh, um, uh, things that I could tell you guys.
Kind of giving you a little more context.
Um, so a little more behind the scenes.
A little more, um, uh, reasoning as to, um, some things happening.
Uh, I'm so sorry for doing this.
I really hate, um, kind of, uh, I, I, I would hope that you guys know that.
I don't like to get myself involved in these types of things unless I'm truly actually involved.
Um, and if, and I felt that this sort of, uh, impacted my, um, streaming activities, uh, enough that I should probably make a statement.
And, um, and, um, and I'm just gonna be pretty frank with you guys.
And I'm not gonna be, um, you know, I'm going to just kind of tell you guys how things are.
And, um, yeah.
So, uh, first I kind of want to give you guys a bit of a timeline of, um, how, how things were with me, um, and my relationship with Bishoujo.
Because I don't make this stream lightly.
Um, so, uh, last year I did the podcast, um, with Matara.
Um, and at that time, uh, I was not, um, I was only working with Bishoujo.
I was not in Bishoujo as a member.
Um, and, uh, you know, we released merch and things like that.
Um, I do want to mention I, uh, did not receive, um, money for that, uh, from any of the merch drop.
Um, but I, uh, you know, it wasn't really about that for me.
So I, um, you know, just kind of wrote it off.
And, you know, Matara and I, we did, uh, from the, we, we have the money from the Patreon itself.
So it was just the merchandise that we did not get paid for.
But, um, uh, you know, I, I, I, I'm trying to figure out how to say this without it sounding too embarrassing.
Um, you know, uh, last year, um, in, like, mid-podcast time that we were recording, um, we had gone to Japan together.
And we had gotten COVID together and we were stuck in a hotel together.
Um, and at that time, I kind of was talking to Matara and I was saying how I, um, how I was, uh, sorry.
Uh, how I, um, was just feeling pretty lonely and how I, um,
uh, sorry, was feeling how I, um, was really wanting to join a group or a company.
And, um, you know, how, you know, V Shoujo would, would be good, but it wasn't exactly goal oriented towards the things I wanted to do.
And, um, in that, on that trip, we had the idea, or we came up with the idea where, um, potentially I could pitch an idol group, Jen, to V Shoujo.
Oh my gosh, it's so weird saying this out loud to you guys right now.
Um, because I've, you know, haven't really told anybody this entire time.
And so, um, uh, I pitched that to them.
And, um, actually, Gunrun and I, uh, knew each other even before I became a VTuber.
Um, we connected through idols.
And so he seemed very keen about the idea.
And so, um, from then I had signed on as a member, technically.
And, um, and, uh, they auditioned for, um, two other members that were going to be, um, that were going to be, uh, a part of the group.
The idol group that we would form.
And, um, so I believe some other people were coming out about their experiences, like, uh, Barry and Pia.
Um, they were not a part of, uh, what I was working on.
They were supposed to be, uh, uh, debuted after us.
And, um, one thing that, uh, I felt very confident in was, um, who we were working with, uh, in Vishojo.
Um, our group actually worked mostly with the JP side of Vishojo.
And, um, uh, things, things were, albeit a bit slow.
Um, things were not bad.
Um, and, uh,
uh, sorry.
Um, I just was really happy that, um, I was working towards a common goal with, um, two other people that, uh, I was really excited to, um, be with.
And, um, uh, um, uh, they were, the staff were really, really good to us, I do want to say.
Um, and, uh, there were a lot of, um, opportunities that were lining up.
Um, and some that, probably,
probably will never come to fruition, but that's okay.
And, uh, sorry.
And, um, so, we actually were initially supposed to, um, debut a while ago, but things kept getting pushed back, pushed back, pushed back.
Which, you know, was understandable at first, but it kind of got a little frustrating with planning certain projects.
And, um, uh, um, I'm trying to, sorry, I'm trying to gather my thoughts so I can give you guys a more transparent idea of what's happening, but also not get in legal trouble.
Um, but, um, uh, they, V Shoujo also helped with my, uh, merch drop that I did after Mosul Box with, like, the mugs and stuff.
Um, I also did not see that money, but I, again, I was so confident about my, you know, my group working out that I, I, sorry.
It wasn't really about that, and I just, you know, kind of said it, it'll be okay, it'll work out.
And, um, sorry.
Uh, so, um, I do want to say, though, that, um, please, you know, obviously support all the talents.
Everybody's kind of going through it.
I'm sorry, it's, I, I am, um, you know, wasn't an, I wasn't an outward-facing talent, but I guess I was a talent for over a year now, I guess.
But, um, but also a lot of the staff are kind of, um, a lot of the, uh, former, uh, staff and a lot of people were, they were really good people.
Um, a lot of them did not know about what was happening until, uh, very recently.
And so, um, uh, our team that we were working with, they told us, they said, you know, we, we want you to, to know what's going on.
Um, and it was, it was a lot, um, and, uh, that's now kind of where we're at present day.
Um, basically everything has, uh, there was, yeah, there was a lot of stuff that was being planned.
And, um, I'm really sorry that, um, I, uh, I, uh, don't have really anything for you guys anymore at the moment.
Um, but, um, but I can say my, um, my 3D, uh, sorry, 3D debut concert should still happen.
Um, and the JP staff were really, really amazing to help that make that happen for me.
Um, and,
yeah, um, I don't really know what else to say.
I didn't want to make this very long anyway.
I just kind of wanted to get this off my chest so I could move forward.
And I'm sorry for, uh, sorry.
I'm sorry for, um, causing this kind of trouble.
And, you know, I like to just keep the vibes good on my channel.
But I felt this was kind of important to bring up.
And so, um,
yeah, I just kind of wanted to, uh, you know, I didn't want to drag this out.
And I'm sorry also for bringing this up as well when there's already so many people coming out about things.
Um, and so much talk.
But, um, uh, thank you guys for, for being here for me.
And I hope that you guys can give you support for everybody else as well.
And, um,
yeah, sorry.
Okay, I think that's all I really needed to say.
I hope that, that cleared some things up for you.
Um, and I, you know, it's really unfortunate that nobody knew how bad it was.
Except the people who knew how bad it was.
And they were just kind of willing to let everyone else walk into a burning building.
And, um, you know, I don't, I, everybody that I worked with was really amazing.
And, um, so I, uh, I'm just really sad that it didn't, you know, have a chance to, to even, even see the light of day.
But, um, yeah, uh, sorry.
Um, thank you for taking the time to listen to me.
And, um, uh, I will continue doing my best.
And hopefully, um, you know, hopefully something will happen for me one day.
Um, we'll see.
I, you know, I really am not good at marketing myself.
Or doing anything like that.
I, so I was really excited about having a company that could help me with opportunities.
And having a group of friends that I could stream with again.
And, um, but, uh, uh, uh, if, I, I guess, you know, the delayed and delays and debut were more of a blessing in disguise.
And, um, I wouldn't be able to do all the things that I can do at the moment without you guys.
So, thank you very much.
And thank you for listening.
Have a good day.
Have a good night.
Thank you.